nach den ersten sommer tagen des jahres
folgten am abend und auch in der nacht
die ersten schweren unwetter über
deutschland mit starkregen und betroffen
vor allem das aatal wieder das a team
muss man sagen an dieser stelle das
letztes jahr ja die jahrhundertflut erst
überstand und jetzt erleben die menschen
dort im aartal wieder voll gelaufene
keller und neue überschwemmungen in der
nacht
starke gewitter und unwetter wütend
aktuell in westdeutschland der deutsche
wetterdienst warnte erneut in der eifel
vor schweren gewittern und gab die
höchste unwetter warnstufe extremes
unwetter heraus besonders heftig traf es
die gegenden im aartal die ortschaften
teils noch zerstört wohnhäuser gerade
fertig mit renovieren und schon wieder
gibt es überflutungen die anwohner sind
geschockt leider kam es heute mittag
ganz nah wie cut warnungen alles recht
nützlich in einer stunde haben wir schon
wieder alle panik geschoben die nachbarn
weil sich der müll eingesammelt einer
social media bewegen wo getreten ist die
folge da die die zeitung wolle die bank
die feuerwehr anzurufen
thb anzurufen
die haben jetzt ein bisschen diese
engstelle besucht
das wasser jetzt ein bisschen besser
abläufe wie wird so ca 10 cm auch schon
wieder gesund man kommt einfach nicht
zur ruhe
zahlreiche keller liefen voll auf den
straßen gab es überflutungen auch das
thw ist im einsatz muss fäkalien aus dem
keller eines frisch renovierten
mehrfamilienhauses heraus pumpen die
unwetter ziehen aktuell weiter nach
osten